you said that if you had to go find a
cheap x-ray or a cheap armchair you
would go to find an armchair if your
life depended on you have to find a
chair today and buy it now
yes versus you have to find an x-ray and
buy it now you would buy the armchair
yes yeah so my question is part of what
allows you to find a cheap armchair is
that there's such a difference in
quality yeah you know you can go and buy
a chair that's 5 bucks probably gonna
break soon yeah
so with health care which I said in the
piece actually yeah yeah so with health
care if it's something you don't you
don't really want to go like some guy
who's offering a five dollar extra and
say hey you want to x-ray you know why
because if it your life depended on it I
don't think that it would be a situation
where you'd be willing to risk the so
let me a let me ask you this why
shouldn't x-ray cost two hundred dollars
a thousand dollars through an insurance
company it's literally a machine an
x-ray technician takes a picture of it
then sends it to a radiologist who
actually looks at it right or doctor
looks at it so I don't know enough about
the healthcare Institute is that well
the reason I'm saying this is because
what I'm saying is that the hell one of
the reasons these things are so much
more expensive and so much less
competitive is because you do not
actually have a free market in
healthcare you have a heavily heavily
regulated market in healthcare if you
want cheap x-rays you have to have a
competition in the x-ray business there
is no competition in the x-ray business
you can't go and look up a list of x-ray
companies they're going to give you an
x-ray today and then call them for the
lowest price in fact if you go into the
doctor right now and you say I want you
to take a look at this x-ray how much
will it cost me the doctor will tell you
I can't give you that answer
alright the doctor will tell you I'm
gonna have to talk to your insurance
company or maybe I may have to run it
through my system and then I'll get back
to you is there any other product in
America where if you went into a
restaurant you said how much is that cup
of coffee they said you drink the cup of
coffee will tell you later right it's
not a free market the point that I was
making with the armchair comparison is
not of course that armchairs are morally
equivalent to health care obviously
people need health care more okay
perhaps it better perhaps a better
comparison would have been bread right
because people need bread okay but the
reason that bread is cheap is because
there's a free market in bread not
because government is subsidizing bread
so the point that I was making is if you
actually want to increase supply the
point I was making in that column and
overall about this is that health care
is not a right health care is a
commodity and the difference in between
those two views that if you think health
care is
right now you're going to use the
government to cram down on doctors that
they must serve you at a particular
price or cram down on taxpayers that
they have to pay for a certain level of
your care or cram down insurance
companies that they can't be insurance
companies anymore they have to be health
coverage institutes essentially which is
when they say you have to accept
pre-existing conditions it's not an
insurance company anymore if you had a
fire insurance company and they said you
have to accept pre-existing conditions
it would just be called the piggy bank
right you'd burn down your house and
then go get fire insurance so that's the
insurance companies don't work that way
so the point I was making is if you view
it as a commodity you're going to end up
making it cheaper more plentiful more
available more competition and the case
in point of this is LASIK eye surgery
which is really unregulated so LASIK eye
surgery used to cost like $20,000 an eye
now cost three four thousand dollars an
eye the reason for that is because the
insurance companies won't cover it and
because there's a competitive market
because it's really expensive right so
lots of doctors now want to be
optometrist or ophthalmologist and do
this sort of into this sort of work this
is why my doctor my wife is a doctor so
I'm very passionate about this
particular topic you know they call it
the road of the road which is the
successful doctors radiologists
ophthalmologist anesthesiologists
dermatologists all those people
basically charge cash and don't work
through insurance companies right the
the vast majority of them work in
high-level private industry and that's
if you wanna make a lot of money that's
what you do and so what you're getting
is in medical schools if you're aiming
for lots of money you go into one of
those for you're not a primary care
physician you're one of those for if you
want more primary care physicians what
should you do you should incentivize it
well Bernie Sanders and the rest of this
crew want to do they declare it a right
and then they take away the incentive
they declared a right for you to have
health care and then they say to the
doctor you're gonna work and you're
gonna like it and we're gonna make you
work and this is why there's a black
market in health care in Canada there's
a black market in Israel there's a black
market in the UK it's why people come
here from all of those places to get
their surgeries so here's the reality
about socialized health care so
socialized health care is good for very
very basic things right it's like
emergency care the same way if you work
it walk into an emergency room today and
you need an x-ray they'll give it to you
regardless of whether you have insurance
which is true this is why in California
have a major problem with illegal
immigrants who don't actually have
health care coverage walking in and to
the ER and using it as their health care
coverage basically the socialized
medicine works the same way except there
is no upper echelon they've made it
equal at the expense of the upper
echelon
meaning that if you now want a surgery
you gotta wait six months online for it
because we didn't give any incentive for
people to become surgeons right there's
no cost-benefit analysis there if you
want more of something you have to
incentivize that thing and when you take
away the market there's no incentive
anymore that's the answer as to why
that's very long answer as to why I say
healthcare is more like a chair than it
is like the air or water because
somebody has to provide it to you